Michael how are you doing yeah and I'm
good how you hanging in there how's the
home situation well you know a little
different I think than most people that
maybe experience and it's back east and
I'm in Arizona and you know you you just
see him the fun for me is different than
the first few days of this when I was
back when I was back east Wendy Field in
Chicago to seeing the Sun and having a
warmth and you know who knows there
certain I actually talk to people the
medical experts who've said the one who
leave their people kept talking about in
their community keep talking about lei
Jun is that you know these viruses
historically I mean even the worst ones
has been seasonal which is well they use
the wrong seasonal before virus and
they're hoping that that plays a part
Sun and a warmth and so that's not
necessarily why I'm here if it's a whole
lot better than being and you know 40
degrees in the rain and just a
depression and the reality of what would
it dealing with right now so I'm here
it's been going well and we're doing
some segments of the show every day I
have a studio that you otherwise
essentially empty I mean just a feeling
I even though I'm sure it's not empty
and it's been as well and when do you
guys think that you'll be back on the
air on pardon the interruption Daniel
what it hasn't come up like when we
might do the show as it has existed for
18 plus years as opposed to doing
segments of the show on SportsCenter it
has not I have a knack I'm sure it's
come up with with the big bosses you
know how that works I have not asked and
happy be doing the amount of the show
that we're doing now I know that's where
we are for this week and I would expect
next week but beyond that I don't know
because I don't know
also which is determined by what
companies feel comfortable with their
employees do it with their staffs doing
and that's that's way above me and I
just don't this guilted to speculate on
it even to ask it like hey guys you know
we will get back to the show nobody
knows and so I just
don't concern myself with it at this
point not yet he's Michael Wilbon the
co-host of pardon the interruption also
covering the NBA for ABC and the
mothership what do you think of the NFL
Draft going on as scheduled here next
month we talked about this Tony I did
yesterday and I guess I think I'm okay
with it but I'm not okay with this ye
general managers saying we can't finish
our psychological profiles you know I
you know I don't need to hear that we
can't have our 11th visit with somebody
to ask them if you were a tree what kind
of tree would you be in the middle of
this is context everything does this
show have to go on if you're the NFL I
guess it doesn't I mean everything this
is an exception to everything we know in
our lives I mean maybe there's like you
know three people alive who can remember
the end of World War one probably not
actually I'm looking at the other day my
my son asked me to dad is there anybody
alive who's around from Spanish Flu and
I said well look looking up but we found
a couple people who are amazing 116 but
this is an exception we didn't no one on
earth knows anything about and so if the
league wants to go on with this
I don't Kate with it I'm not offended by
it if they said you know like everything
else we're gonna push this a little bit
I'd be okay with that too this isn't one
of those things that has me agitated
like some other things that are going on
during this yeah as long as you can do
your job and I had a source say you know
these executives these Scouts GM saying
hey I can't do my job he said remember
when Cleveland moved to Baltimore they
had no time to do any interviews and
their first two draft picks with Ozzie
Newsome were to Hall of Famers in
Jonathan Ogden and Ray Lewis and he said
if you do your job the entire year then
you should be ready to have a draft
tomorrow if you've done your job you
should be able to you know conduct your
draft your war room tomorrow so yeah but
I agree with that dad you know I mean
these guys are so I don't want to say
prepared I mean yes if you've done your
job or anything I mean how many times
are they gonna look at a guy how many
times we have to have them in under
under normal conditions okay fine you
tolerate it but to say that has to
happen this year
well we can't have a draft right now and
you push it push it away and how do you
know you're gonna get that chance I look
at I understand being able to just give
someone a simple physical but in most of
these cases I suspect they're not
talking about that we're talking about
the extreme ruin storage teams and their
personnel evaluators go and we just I
don't have the stomach to hear excuses
about that right now
all right a couple things here I I said
I wouldn't get to get mad anymore
I watched the opening night when they
had the brackets for the greatest
college basketball player of all time
and and I don't know if I've been this
upset truly upset on this show
and all of a sudden I saw where Zion
moves moves on past Danny Manning Shaq
moves on got me
but then Shack over Lew Alcindor Jerry
West is a 13 seed Maravich is a 13 seed
tray young had half a great season at
Oklahoma like what what happened here
the generations we've what we wait
there's two generations of people that
with no regard or interest in history
no none we need to do a correction show
we need to delete just call it get off
my lawn let's get off my lawn I'd be
timepiece I was good so then it's so
funny obviously you have not talked
sisters started for the night that first
of all I'm just angry about it anyway
don't put together a bracket that has
your women and men have a level women's
bracket women's field and a men don't
ask Cheryl don't answer the Cheryl
Miller is better than Bill Walton or
whatever they just don't do it it's just
it's lazy and I hate it I hate it and
the knife is ion was advanced past Damon
no one knows what
damn it so so my son who so all we've
done sleep in the same house for I want
he gave its fight about it gets big good
it's been fun it's fight about sports in
history and he came to me in a proud
moment yesterday on his 12th birthday
and he said dad if I I guess is mad and
he's playing I don't know I don't owe
him anything
this is dead if I have Deacon Jones on
my defensive line I know yes I just
dreaming yeah
yes how do you even come about his name
but he comes back to me later he goes ok
dad I get I get what you're saying so if
I have Joe green and Deacon John yeah
yes yes there's no plus yardage play
against you if you have them and I'm
screaming at them because you know the
up 70% of time I'll beat him or maybe
not as hell he's pretty good at this age
you know coming me and say so is
so-and-so going the Hall of Fame it's
like you know it's some player who I've
almost forgotten about who just happens
to play now and we've got two
generations of people who don't know
anything and they don't care and you
can't talk them out of it it's like
listening they don't care about anything
and dentists not just sports I guarantee
you they don't know in World War water
they'll just say I don't care
god I'm Spanish fluid or whatever I
don't happen before I was born
well it's so angry I I have three
daughters so we don't talk sports but
when they talk music and they'll say hey
Dad I was wondering about Bowie I guess
yes the guess whatever you're wondering
about is great you know what's your
favorite Zeppelin why just listen to him
one other thing I wanted to ask you
about and I brought this up a couple of
weeks ago I think I was talking about
the most impactful I guess I was talking
about Lew Alcindor
and I cuz he's the greatest college
basketball player of all times not even
a question and I said you know there
were a couple of impactful games in my
life college basketball games Texas
Western beating Kentucky so you had your
first all-black starting 5 with Don
Haskins at Texas Western
magic and bird but also Lew Alcindor
organs Elvin Hayes in the Astrodome
those are the three games that I had I
think have and maybe I'm missing one
have had the biggest impact on the sport
because the first all-black starting
five wins the title against an all-white
Kentucky team bird magic the
highest-rated college basketball game
but prime basketball was in primetime in
the Astrodome with Lew Alcindor against
Elvin Hayes and the Houston Cougars so
is there another one you'd put in there
and if not out of those five I share
that with you I'm gonna say maybe I mean
the anniversary I think it's today girl
Walton 21 or 22 Bill Walton that game
that he that he had I'm gonna put that
up there but also magic burns
anniversary today oh wow
well that one the first one the one I
mentioned Walton is less culturally
impactful than the one you mentioned why
I'm with you on your selection of those
three the the Laettner the hill too late
their game does it wasn't in the Final
Four for one but it doesn't have a
cultural impact although it to me that
still has a certain I'm it certain
importance a certain glamour that's the
best game ever called that's the best
way best college game everywhere yeah
yeah what about the David Kahn thing
that was a semi final game against UCLA
you know and I don't my treatment of now
is now for me being old over George
Sherrill I wasn't as surprised at
Villanova one that is everybody else
wanted to five either but they played to
close games in regular I was a
Georgetown be try that yeah and I
covered every Georgetown game and I
remember before the game my we was
getting the block together a book on
Georgetown season immediately after like
stay up all night the next two nights
and my editor I called my editor just
before the tip and I said so what
happens is little would be scored
and I said do you realize that one of
the games would like double overtime in
the regular season and the other game
was like three points I don't know the
film in this game and I was watching the
games on the mothership before they used
to play I was a new thing and I asked
edy pick me after the game when did you
really think you could beat Georgia he
goes I'm sitting around in the hotel and
I see the games we played he's like oh
my god we really beat things wise and it
was the same feeling that no one
everybody called it the biggest upset
except you know there were hints that
this wasn't going to be necessarily a
big upset be on with you on those damn
those are the the Hall of Fame moments
in college basketball which if you think
you know about the sport and you're not
familiar with those you need to shut up
they go to YouTube or wherever you go
and and and seek them out and learn
about the moments that shaped college
basketball it's good to talk to you keep
yelling at people to get off your lawn
Mike thank you Mike that's Michael
Wilbon co-host pardon the interruption
of course covers the NBA as well